I believe I'm 16 in adults and this
question is the mainstream concept or
definition of Gotham City
and if it isn't is it possible for it
got to exist within space and time
without disregarding the laws of nature
Emira if I understood your question is
the idea of God's self defeating
I don't think so a lot of people around
the world believe in God and they seem
to conduct affairs pretty okay Kenna God
exists in space-time
well according to all my friends who are
deeply religious yes and that would be
the trouble with it is if I understand
your question it's hard to provide
evidence for that it's hard to provide
evidence for a god that you can't see or
detect and and then to draw conclusions
about what that God he or she did based
on phenomena that that people in on my
side of it can explain without this
supernatural influence that's where you
that's where I think your question
arises you're asking a deep
philosophical question I don't know the
answer is there a god or not that exists
in space-time but but I always ask
myself and others is what would you do
differently how would it change your the
way you live your life if you knew that
there was no God or if you knew that
there was what would you do differently
would you start committing crimes
would you stop committing crimes would
you quit your regular job and help
people everywhere as hard as you could
living a very modest life or would you
try to accumulate as wealth much wealth
as possible without regard to others
like what would you do differently if
you knew the answer of your question and
my for me I wouldn't do anything
differently I just try to lead a good
life be responsible for my own actions
and leave the world better than I found
it that's those are my goals you can
decide whether or not it's successful
great question the mirror is cool
[Music]